[Music]
here in this video we will take a look
at whether there are other alien species
that have become predators or hunters
including humans and whether we are one
of the most dangerous preys for the
yautjas to hunt
so a predator's primary existence is the
sport and honor-based hunting of other
dangerous species and although they are
a singular species there are many
variations and subspecies in their foe
and if they can work things out without
falling apart then the question begs
can other alien species become blooded
predators
well most if not all predators are
indeed yelljust and they themselves only
become hunters when they undergo through
a ritual of hunting a very dangerous
brave species mostly either a quadza
ridge or a xenomorph and to do this they
have to stick to a set of rules that are
regarded as their code of honor if the
yacht just succeed then their immediate
seniors declare them blooded and
qualified to become hunters and hunt
alone if their code of honor is broken
then they are considered bad blood and
are subsequently killed for it or exiled
and declared as heretics so to answer
the question can other species become
predators the answer is yes if they
prove themselves in a bloody ritual or
some sort of similar situation although
there have only been one other species
other than the yautjas that have been
blooded as hunters and accepted into a
clan
so to answer the question are there
humans who have become predators or
accepted into a predator clan the answer
is yes humans as of now have been the
only species to have been considered and
blooded as hunters
yajna motivations for hunting are not
just for sport but rather for honor with
the species having developed a whole
tribal culture around their status at
the top of the food chain their code of
honor dictates what makes a worthy
adversary and thus will make a predator
or clan more respected so surprising as
it may seem certain humans like lex
woods and machiko noguchi met the
criteria of fulfilling a bloody ritual
or unknowingly by their character
quality and fighting skills met the code
of honor of the predators and as such
were blooded as hunters by the elders or
the elite predators
there accepting them into one of their
clans
so what's the story behind the human
predators
there are three notable females that
have been accepted into a clan or have
been blooded by predators machiko
noguchi ash panel and lex woods are them
each coming from a different time with a
different backstory but the common thing
is that they have hunted or killed a
xenomorph that was either infesting the
earth or another planet in doing so and
assisting a predator in the hun they
were blooded by the pack leaders
machiko and lex wurtz both had killed or
assisted in the hunt of a queen
xenomorph and ash panel was credited
with hunting down the cinema of human
predator white hybrids machika was even
given predator armor and crafted her own
bio helmet and was properly a part of a
clan
there is one other human that although
wasn't blooded as a hunter in the normal
ways that the others were with the mark
from xenomorph blood was indeed
considered a hunter and was even
supplied with yautja equipment for a
hunt
this was roy's yes the same one from the
movie predators of 2010 although the
movie ended in a cliffhanger the comics
continued
and he was given specially crafted wrist
blades armor and a biohelmet design for
him especially to hunt down the deadly
forearm predator
or maybe he was a hybrid predator a
mutated one and with the help of isabel
the israeli commando they did the deed
and so these are the only human
predators till date
so about the other question are we one
of the most dangerous prey for the
yadgers the answer is a bit tricky
if we were to compare let's say a common
man from the streets in a one-on-one
battle against a predator then the odds
of him even knowing what hit him are
slim
but in certain cases when highly skilled
individuals have learned about the
existence of these aliens and know their
tricks and trait they often come out on
top trapping and killing the predators
using their own strengths as a weakness
as in the cases of almost every predator
movie and some instances in the comics
as well
what makes us dangerous well humans
might not be the ultimate prey which are
reserved for the xenomorphs or a rival
species such as the engineers or even
feared by them like the drukathi but we
are still considered highly dangerous
especially in groups and if well armed
capable of hunting down the predators
themselves and making a quick job of
xenomorphs and even river ghosts and in
special cases earning the respect of the
yaw jazz and accept it into their clan
as one of them
so what are the predator to human death
rates in encounters
well the count is high in human deaths
but at the end of almost every movie the
predator or predators do meet there and
at the hands of
people
dutch in the first movie handedly killed
the predator
then harrigan also did the same thing to
the city hunter in alien vs predator
requiem wolf was killed in a nuclear
strike by the united states military
in predators the three super predators
were killed by a suicide blast a katana
duel and by roy's beheading the leader
of the clan
even the upgrade predator the one that
easily butchered the fugitive predator
was in the end defeated and killed by
quinn and casey ending his life by
headshots and now with prey the feral
predator although having a killing spree
in the movie was in the end defeated by
a girl
so that's it that's the video i hope you
have enjoyed watching this one so do hit
that like button for support and
subscribe as well but most of all smash
the bell icon for regular updates on new
videos
right here on this channel till the next
one take care fam